hallo leute heute werden wir euch etwas
typisch deutsches vorstellen das
abendbrot
vielleicht habt ihr es schon einmal bei
einem besuch in deutschland
kennengelernt
viele menschen in deutschland essen
abends kalt das heißt sie kochen kein
warmes abendessen und dann gibt es das
wort schon sagt abendbrot wir werden
euch heute zeigen was dazu gehört
los geht's
[Musik]
ich werde für dich heute ein typisch
deutsches abendessen vorbereiten lacke
german abendessen
das wird richtig lecker freust du dich
schon früher das abendbrot wird übrigens
oft von sogenannten holzbrettchen
gegessen die nennt man brettchen eignen
sich gut die sind flach man kann darauf
gut lebensmittel schneiden und daher
sind die gut fürs anbot so das abendbrot
ist fertig jetzt zeige ich euch einmal
was dazu gehört
und zwar das wichtigste brot wer mir ein
großes helles brot ein vollkornbrot und
eine brezel leute nutzen ganz
verschiedene brote es gibt sehr sehr
viele brote in deutschland dann haben
wir eine käseplatte mit verschiedenen
weichkäse und hartkäse sorten dann haben
wir noch eine wusste wer butter wir
haben verschiedene kleine gemüse sachen
tomaten salat gurke radieschen wir haben
auch eingelegte gurken auch celica
was haben wir noch hart gekochte eier
die gibt es so bunt immer zur osterzeit
dann natürlich ein gutes bier zum
abendessen und noch ein paar saucen
remoulade wer's mag sehr lecker auf
wurst auch und auf anderen sachen sind
ja das ist eigentlich erst mal alles man
kann das sehr weit aus wald man kann
auch salat machen und viele viele schöne
dinge die man mag jetzt geht's los
[Musik]
übrigens wenn ihr noch mehr kabel lernen
wollt dann probiert doch mal den
vokabeltrainer unserer app sie länger
aus dort findet ihr die 6.000
wichtigsten deutschen vokabeln mit
aussprache trainings und beispielsätzen
und die app ist jetzt auch im app store
und im google places verfügbar
das brot ist fertig
ja
[Musik]
das abendbrot ist übrigens in den
letzten jahrhunderten entstanden weil
arbeiter mittags eine warme und deftige
mahlzeit benötigten um in die zweite
arbeitsphase des tages zu starten
so brauchte man abends nur noch eine
kalte mahlzeit und das war dann das
abendbrot auch durch den technischen
fortschritt der den menschen schwere
arbeit abnahm war es dann ordnung abends
nur noch etwas kaltes zu essen
heutzutage essen auch viele menschen
abends warm weil sie den tag über im
büro in der uni oder in der schule sind
und es abends zum kochen kommen
allerdings halten immer noch 50 prozent
der deutschen an der tradition des
abends fest
das schmeckt lecker
[Musik]
ein belegtes brot nimmt man übrigens
auch butterbrot es gibt aber auch andere
regionale bezeichnungen für ein
butterbrot zum beispiel sagt man in
berlin
und auch hier im nordwesten stühle oder
schnitte im rheinland butter kennen im
ruhrgebiet knüpfte im erzgebirge vize
und in sachsen
wir hoffen euch hat das abendbrot
gefallen
wir haben schon oft gehört dass menschen
überrascht waren wenn sie nach
deutschland haben und ein kaltes
abendbrot zum abendessen bekommen haben
jetzt hat es am ende doch ganz gut
gefallen schreibt man in die kommentare
ob ihr schon mal ein abendbrot in
deutschland gegessen hat oder ob wir
vielleicht auch abends contest und wenn
ihr jetzt noch mehr vokabeln lernen
wollt dann probiert doch wirklich mal
den vokabeltrainer unserer app sieht
lecker aus
die jetzt auch im app store und im
googleplex store verfügbar ist bis bald
[Musik]
tolles wagnis